hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my Game of Thrones Season eight episode
five Q&A video so here we go I picked
all these questions for my episode 5
video in my episode 6 finale trailer
video so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Game of
Thrones videos will have prequel stuff
coming up in the next couple of weeks
it was actually just revealed that
they've started shooting the Game of
Thrones prequel series already in
Northern Ireland so we'll talk about
that in a separate video later this week
because it's not related to what Dan and
Dave are doing they're not gonna be
associated with Game of Thrones TV shows
going forward so all the prequel stuff
will be completely different creative
teams working with george RR martin
there's a new round of the HBO now
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video and obviously spoiler warning
for everything through episode 5 in the
episode 6 finale trailer so here we go
first question is Jonathan Quinn asks do
you think that Cersei is still alive in
Tyrion kills her out of mercy before
Daenerys executes her betraying her gets
himself killed no I definitely think
that Cersei and Jaime were supposed to
have died in that cave in I think people
have become so attuned to surprises on
Game of Thrones that anytime you see a
big character seemingly die and you
don't see the body in the way that you
saw kai burns death like you actually
saw his corpse sitting there but after
the episode aired Lena Headey and
Nikolaj coster-waldau in real life were
doing the typical post that actors do
when they're not gonna be playing their
characters anymore like I love this so
much it was such a great opportunity for
me it changed my life all the customary
r.i.p posts that actors give to their
characters
next question Geena Julian asks no one
seems to be addressing this but what was
the favor Tyrion was asking of Davos
what did he want him to smuggle I
believe he was arranging for this gift
to be out back to that escape route that
Jaime was gonna use to take him in
Cersei to Pentos even if he wasn't gonna
sail them to Pentos himself the whole
idea is that he's a smuggler so he was
gonna help smuggle them out of the
King's Landing area next question coach
jts do you think that Arya Stark will
kill Daenerys and become the savior of
Westeros after she rode off on that
white horse then talking about the
symbolism of the white horse and
mythology yeah I do think they're going
for heavy symbolism with the white horse
but I don't think that Arya would
ultimately be the person to kill
Daenerys if that is what's going to
happen as the faceless person Arya
serves the many-faced God which is
basically a representation of death the
way they think about it
she serves death death has many faces I
look forward to meeting this one when
she was talking about the night king in
the night King was almost a literal
interpretation of death kind of a
walking death but there's a passage in
the New Testament talking about the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse and it says I
looked and behold an ashen and he who
sat on it had the name death so it was
almost like Aria is death riding a pale
horse so I was making heavy metaphors
about creeping death
Aria coming for Daenerys but obviously
the show harps a lot on subverting
expectations so I don't think that aria
ultimately would be the person to kill
Daenerys but I do think that she's
definitely gonna get close and try to do
it next question rht 785 s still not
convinced why Daenerys use the nuclear
option I mean okay to destroy enemies
but civilians that goes a hundred
percent against what she did in all the
show so the thing about that is that you
have to remembers that she did burn a
lot of her enemies there are a lot of
quotes that people have pulled from her
across the series - that implied that
she's very ready to burn everyone if
they don't do what she says when my
dragons are grown we will take back what
was stolen from me and destroy it those
are wrong to me we will lay waste to
armies and burn cities to the ground
turn us away and we will burn you first
a better metaphor would probably be
heard going around slavers Bay trying to
eliminate slavery like during the Battle
of marine way back during season four
Daenerys took marine by force crucified
all the wise masters than if you're
thinking logically there was probably a
lot of collateral damage during those
fights that they just did not show you
on screen they tried to do a better job
of that in later seasons when the
harpies started to rise up to try and
oust her out of marine like towards the
end of season five but got real bad it
wasn't just the harpies that were trying
to get rid of her it was actually a lot
of the locals too that wanted things to
go back to the old way just because it
was such a part of their culture and
especially up to dance with Dragons the
most recent book she becomes incredibly
impatient about acting on her plans like
during Episode four when they were
trying to counsel Daenerys that they
just blockade King's Landing in await
Cersei out and she wouldn't have it no
we need to go right now
she's liked that a lot in the books so
there is something there's a lost
between book Daenerys and TV show
Daenerys in translation and it's just
another big thing
the laundry list of problems that the
show has had trying to adapt the
narrative especially doing into such a
condensed way but if you haven't read
the books obviously you wouldn't have
gotten that extra context so if you are
a show only watcher is totally
forgivable if you feel like this twist
came out of nowhere and you weren't
expecting it next question amber herring
asks is Daenerys gonna spring a baby on
us in the last episode yeah I gotta say
I don't think it's gonna happen had they
had more seasons they might have done
something like that the whole idea is is
that on the TV show the last couple of
seasons as well as in the books they
heavily foreshadow that Daenerys will
eventually become pregnant again
but the thing is is there are a lot of
things from the books that the TV show
has not done so in the alternate
universe version of events where they
say do 10 seasons of Game of Thrones
what might have happened is that
Daenerys would become pregnant towards
the final seasons and then maybe she
also loses that baby in some tragic
event and that also helps push her
towards Mad Queen faster but the way it
seems like they're going there's just so
much stuff that they have to wrap up in
the finale I think the ending will be
tragic enough that we don't also need to
pile a dead baby on top of that too so
just call that Jon Snow Daenerys baby
that she might have had a casualty of
the show condensing the story so much
next question Yoji sue asks do you think
that bran will kill Daenerys with a
Lannister crossbow bolts to secure his
castle the Tyrion owes him well to
answer your first question no I don't
think that he's going to be involved
with Daenerys as potential death if she
does wind up dying and I don't know if
he's gonna get his castle either because
that was a Lannister promise not a stark
promise you have to remember who's gonna
be left alive if Daenerys winds up dying
and it was Jamie in Tyrion that promised
bran the castle so that would depend on
whether or not you think Tyrion is gonna
be alive at the end of the story - and
remember Daenerys did say that she
basically killed him if she failed him
again and it does sound like Tyrion has
already betrayed her by helping Jaime
escape so it's a pretty safe bet that
he's walking on eggshells and his days
are numbered
next question Cherise asks if Daenerys
dies would dro Khan accept Jon as his
new rider I think part of the idea at
the beginning of the season when drogon
gave him that big stare is that he
didn't want of anything to do with
anything that was not Daenerys the sound
designer that actually makes the sound
that the Dragons make said that in this
moment the way she was playing it is is
that drogon was telling Jon Snow that
the only person
she rides is me it'd be like if you
tried to go on a date with a girl and
you came to her house and her dog got
really territorial there was a deleted
scene where John talked about having a
mental link with ragle a little bit but
because it's an outtake I don't think
the show is ever fully gonna address
that so no I didn't expect anybody to
write drogon after Daenerys if she winds
up dying next question Stephanie asks
why did Jon reject Daenerys is all about
that staunch Ned Stark honor very bad
thing within the context of a game of
Thrones now remember when Daenerys has
small Council got upset with Jon Snow
earlier on the show why couldn't you
just lied to her this one time why do
you have to be so dang honorable the
whole idea of Ned Stark's honor getting
him killed is that he felt like he was
compelled to out Joffrey as a bastard as
the son of Jamie Lannister
so he ran to the castle to proclaim it
to everyone that would hear this boy
does not belong in the Iron Throne he
was not prepared for the game the
Lannisters were playing Littlefinger
obviously backstabbed him I told you you
shouldn't trust me therefore I think one
of the underlying messages of Game of
Thrones is that too much honor is a very
bad thing and obviously like Jon just
felt like it was the wrong thing to do
it was dishonorable for someone to marry
someone that they were related to or to
be with them in a relationship next
question Melissa asks if George are
Martin is saying the main characters
ends will mostly be the same I don't
understand how Circe's valonqar prophecy
is then fulfilled well one of the cheats
that the show gave itself is that it
excluded the valonqar part of Maggie the
frogs prophecy there were a lot of
people after the episode that saw that
Jamie's hands were sort of wrapped
around Circe's neck a little bit so you
could say that they tried to fulfill a
version of the valonqar but it wasn't a
literal interpretation of the prophecy
like during my finale trailer video
yesterday I talked about Jon Snow
becoming azor Ahai if he potentially
killed Daenerys she would be his Nissa
Nissa which is a big part of the azure
Ahai prophecy but the show has never
tried to be literal with the way it
fulfills prophecies so you have to think
of them paying these off in a more
metaphorical way so like Jon forges
Lightbringer by plunging it through
Daenerys his breasts
that doesn't mean that his sword would
start glowing like a lightsaber or
anything like that I mean it would glow
red with her blood but that's about it
so when we're talking about valonqar use
that to think about it that way so kind
of wrapping his hands around her neck
and jamie is the younger of
two twins Cersei actually came out of
their mother's womb first so technically
he is the quote-unquote younger one next
question Ignacio asks do you think the
brand has anything to do with the white
horse that appeared in front of Aria can
we expect anything from bran no I don't
think he had anything to do with the
white horse I think that was just the
show going for that metaphor of Arya
being death riding a pale horse bran is
still alive he's at Winterfell right now
so I do think he's going to show up
during the finale sometime all the main
characters that are still alive will
probably appear during the finale at
some point the next question Levu asks
in your Q&A video would you do a segment
addressing your own opinion of what's
happening so far in the season like how
do you actually feel about it and if you
have any criticism I think I've been
pretty clear about my biggest criticisms
the last couple of episodes in
particular just them trying to cram way
too much of the story into too few a
number of episodes there's never been a
bigger disparity between the high
quality of the actual technical aspects
of the episodes and the filmmaking
quality and the quality of the writing
in the narrative so obviously I think
most of us aren't really happy with the
way the scripts have gone down and the
way they're pacing the story out and a
lot of this could just be solved they
had done a couple extra seasons but the
way Dan and Dave explain it is that the
HBO tried to pay them more money to do
more episodes and they turned them down
so it's totally understandable if you're
really upset about the way this went
down when really we should have had at
least another 20 or so episodes just to
flesh all of these character arcs out
next question silver Phoenix asks do you
think that Martin has already finished
the books the actor that plays Barristan
Selmy said that in an interview there oh
there were a lot of people asking about
this the last couple of days Georgia or
Martin got pissed he came out recently
to debunk that theory he's like no I
haven't even started writing dream of
spring yet so no I don't think that he's
finished the books I do believe Martin
when he says he's not finished with
winds of winter yet in the actor that
plays Barristan Selmy was probably just
mistaken when he said that
next question Nicole asks can you make a
video about how the books do a better
job of foreshadowing how Danny will
eventually go mad I'll probably do a
video after the season is up about all
the prophecies they fulfilled and all
the big character arcs and things like
that so I am starting to make that list
right now if there are any really
special videos that you guys want me to
do after the season is over just let me
know in the comments too but there'll be
obviously a lot of bonus videos coming
and then I'll start doing videos
the prequel series too because like I
said they actually just started filming
the Game of Thrones prequel this week
thank you so much everyone for
submitting questions these are always
fun to do obviously I'll do the same
thing for the finale video and then that
bonus episode seventh they're doing
after that too
quick reminder about that there's a
special episode that's airing the week
after the finale so it's not meant to be
a canonical episode it's just like a
bonus episode on top of the season I
will do a video for that just like I
would for any of the other episodes so
no worries congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video
Amelia Hernandez please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my season 8
episode 6 finale trailer video we're in
the end game now and click here for my
episode 5 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you